you've got to you've got to play it
again dude whole thing what would you
think about that the very end is my
favorite
thing ever D I'm telling you I think
that that's the best submission we've
ever
got
Runk hello
hello
hello hello will you please
hello hello
hello well oh welcome to the show it's
called lifeline and you love it it's
episode 80 I think you do you do you
know 81 episode 81 wow I would have I
had I if you asked me I would have no
idea what episode extremely close
couldn't have been closer and I'm smart
couldn't have been closer what kind of
shirt is that a gray one I know but what
kind uh dude you know what I just
thought of Chris you Chris I thought of
uh greymond how a dude we used to go to
middle school with Kevin Anderson I know
him he would you knew Kevin yeah he
would just anything anything he would
add mon to the end like Pokemon you know
and he had a lighter once and he's like
this is Greymon wow just cuz it was a
gay lighter I don't know but we still
say it he started by saying he had a
bong that he called smokemon oh right
smokemon and then like Pokemon yeah did
the okay and then what and then we
started saying smoke Mon's pubis too cuz
it's oh yeah you remember I do yeah you
remember that cool uh man didn't answer
ask about the shirt is it h i I don't
know oh okay this this is how I let
people check my tab
okay L's end oh I like L end do you yeah
I like yeah they got cool like I don't
even know if they're still a brand but
they got cool like ' 80s 90s like not
outdoor gear but kind of like kind of
like L Bean you know uh L Bing Bong H
Bing b
binging ladies love Bean ladies love
when I say Bing binging binging so
annoying people turned it off oh episode
81 Sunday October 29th and Sunday's off
for Lifeline go sign up for Lifeline
luxury that's uh patreon.com Lifeline
luxury uh and you can do that now now
check this out I'm on tour why is it not
up yet go go figure you know what I mean
go figure right especi cuz last time we
go you know what happened last time not
up and uh the thing that happened last
time is that you got mad when it wasn't
up and you would think right right right
right it would be ready to go this time
but it wasn't was okay but I'll be in
Long Beach November 2nd uh I'll be in
Orlando Florida Fort Mars Florida
Richmond Virginia Baltimore Maryland
Trenton New Jersey Philadelphia reading
and Oxnard California go to Chris
lea.com to get
ticks um and if you have a question
click the link description description
description below or go to watch
lifeline.com
if you want a one-on-one advice session
with Matt deia Matt deia matt.com baby
I'll save your life if you let me if you
are so gracious as to let me save your
life I will save your life hi Johnny and
then Lifeline merch is at lifeline
merch.com and it's absolutely beautiful
you got to go on there and get that uh
you know what I did today did you say
the thing about luxury I did yeah okay
great go
ahead what you thing that I did what did
you do today Chris um we were talking
about clothes you know your shirt
yeah uh I you don't need to tie it in
you could just say you know so shirts
we're on you know how you're wearing
shirts
okay I got an
email from a
place uh that I've ordered stuff from
before right like clothes I don't really
look at them those emails but sometimes
I do yeah I you mean I never look at
those things but I know she talking but
sometimes they do because I'm like what
do they got right sucker it's why they
send them yeah right but I got but I'm
like I'm not really in the market to buy
anything right now I have enough
whatever I
need I click on it and I see a very very
very very cool jacket and then what
happened and I clicked on it to go to
the website it took me to go to the
website and I looked at it and the
jacket was
$1,100 and I did not buy it smartart I
want to and I still want to and I've
been thinking about it all day let's
talk about this what kind of shirt is
that represent I don't know what that is
but that is maybe your best teach shirt
that's a great shirt why why I don't
know I really like it I don't know what
I have a bunch of shirts that are this
that are different colors with the r on
it like this oh yeah well that's good
then because it's not the color that I
like I do like the color but that's a
cool design yeah I wear probably the
most t-shirts I wear I represent it's a
it's a UK based company how about this
when people say represent well then that
that actually makes me want to not wear
the shirts yeah you hate that but that's
not true though now I have a question
for you though okay there's these
glasses uh-huh such fashion forward
episode
and then there's also these glasses so
why do you have two pair of glasses on
you that's not where I wanted to take it
you can ask me that after I didn't want
to take it with the [__] smokey Mon's
thing but you did it I I didn't want I
was I was operating something though I
was driving us somewhere and you took us
to some you took us off I understand but
you did the Pokémon thing when I was
talking about gray the gray shirt you're
like oh you know what I thought of
chrism so I didn't even mean to get you
back but I did get back so tip fortat
but I didn't mean to okay okay so what
did you ask me why do you have two
glasses on you for this reason you
brought them to just show on the show
yeah oh no I'm not done yet dude which
pair do you like better and which pair
do you all like better cuz it's not the
main pair I wear but it's the secondary
pair what's the secondary pair whichever
one you like more whichever one they
like oh I see so you have two they're
not new though are they new no okay well
what this doesn't matter this doesn't
matter it does I'm trying to establish a
pecking order of glasses I understand
but why if they're not new why are you
doing this now because I just thought of
it okay I have another question before
we even get into it okay go did you were
they in your car or do you put them in
your car to bring them here to do this
they were sitting next to my keys I
grabbed the wrong glasses and I thought
oh you know what I'm going to bring the
other pairs as well to do the thing on
the show so I can talk about it that
really satisfies me thank you and I'm
pissed at you though okay so can I see
the other ones again oh my god well I
man I I now I want to take in the whole
thing cuz you said there's these and
then there's these and I didn't really
look at the first ones now I see these
okay okay I'm I model glasses I get it
Charlie fat ass is in my way well you
picked them up on you which ones are
better I think probably those are better
technically okay but these are cool too
they're fashion you know they're a
little different though you know fashion
these used to be my main pair but you
know what happened Calvin bit them and
scratched the [__] out of him but I
still I almost threw him away but I kept
him because I thought it was cute that
Calvin [__] up my glasses and that's
like a cute thing however gives me a
headache when I worm too long really
yeah just cuz of a little scratch it's
in the wrongest Place whoa really [__]
with my Focus cuz it's right in the
wrong place so where are the other ones
then I decided that those are the great
the main ones are in my bag well what
are those then I'm trying to establish a
pecking order of glasses I already know
what this be number two number three oh
okay well that's two well maybe I think
that's one though I don't know the other
one so now I'm wearing three I don't
care I know that's number one if you
have the number one in your bag why are
you not wearing the number one because I
wear it all the time I wear them all the
time everybody knows so you wanted to
take a little break from
it no I just all I wanted to do was
establish a pecking order to do the
thing stop saying pecking order dude I'm
never going to stop saying pecking order
Gregory pecking order dude so what you
wanted to do
is not wear those to do this so you
could get the pecking order oh wait do I
have I might have the regular ones in my
bag I'm not sure I honestly don't there
we go I don't know okay well whatever I
like the other ones and then you're
being disrespectful I'm wearing those
cuz I like I put the bronze on okay I'll
put I'll put the silver
on I got the silver let's see I think
those are probably better
okay I'm not saying I don't like the
other ones though now what does
everybody else think let us know in the
comments leave in the comments you likes
uh you likes gray or clear gray or clear
yes uh well that's that's great um but
you know I don't know so you you don't
think I should have got that jacket no I
don't even know what it looks like but
that's too much for money you know it's
very cool I bet it is but you know what
I don't need it sometimes we don't get
the things that we really want CU we
know I know it's not gratifi what kind
or do you not want to say yeah what was
the brand why would I not want to say it
because I don't want people to get it
you're being extra annoying tonight
you're being extra annoying tonight I'm
not going to say it because what if I do
want to get it and then this episode
comes out I can't get anymore because
our Legion of fans all got them
everyone's just going to get an $1,100
jacket that's not a thing most people do
yeah I'm not going to do I'm not going
to do it though but was it the kith one
no it wasn't and if it was I wouldn't
say it Anthony the [__] guy trying to
expose me no it's not is there a new kit
jacket out the one I sent you oh that
one no it wasn't that one was that 1100
yes it was oh wow it's funny dude every
time Anthony opens his [__] mouth yeah
Charlie goes like this I I know cuz
Charlie cuz ah it's true animals can
sense evil you guys you guys you know
what that's from no what is it from Ace
Ventura cool that's great I love Ace
Ventura I know other lines from it most
of them uhow my dog Charlie's here this
is my
dog oh yeah oh [__] I didn't realize it
was
Charlie I didn't realize it was Charlie
oh would you think it was bnie I thought
it was one of one of those one of his
dogs one of those dogs no this is
Charlie the one and only hey Charlie so
uh all right well I'm getting my haircut
it's going to be this is it it's as long
as it's been for a long time looks good
why are you getting it cut because it's
too long according to what uh I'm I'm 43
I think once you're in your
40s this is it it can't be any longer
than this that's a you made that up yeah
but I think it's how it should be okay
if you're in your 40s and you have hair
longer than this it's it's too much it's
just too much and there you have it
folks okay um I guess it is pretty
[__] long your hair's not usually
that long yeah kind of Rees does it I
mean he's the man too so you just got
I'm the man you just got utterly
debunked I'm the man but you're saying
if you're over 40 and you have hair that
long it's not good he is well over 40
and he's the man prob honestly looks
better with it cut short maybe I don't
but he doesn't care dude does care the
best thing about keano is how little he
cares is true he cares about like being
nice it's it's not fair to really do it
with a guy with I mean Jared letto and
Cano look way younger than they than
they are so it's not really fair J is
50 I mean yeah so over 50 and he looks
like that it's crazy it's really weird
yeah what kind of like adrenochrome [__]
Z guy up to you know well that doesn't
exist but yeah oh really I know that you
know
uh I I oh adicor doesn't actually exist
and make people look younger become
younger become younger um yeah so anyway
all right well look that's cool it's
good we we got through that all right
great uh do you want to do a a
submission yeah so nervous to ask me if
I want to do a submission it should go
okay it should go okay all yeah let's
have it so dark Matt long time Log Cabin
Constructor here um quick question kind
of pertains to me um my situation is a
little more complicated but what do you
think about girls who uh you know you've
been seeing for a while and um you know
try to get a real relationship going
what do you think about when they say
the timing isn't right or they want to
just work on themselves um do you think
that's just a way to kind of get out of
it even you know in my situation
everything was going absolutely
fantastic it would have made sense for
us to be in a relationship but they had
said that uh you know the timing isn't
right and like I said they they wanted
to focus on themselves is that [__]
is that a way out of it uh let me know
your thoughts thanks yeah but what do
you mean by like [__] like I mean they
don't like them but here's the thing
like if that person was really really
into you she wouldn't say I need to work
on myself so it's not necessarily that
they don't like you it's that
like you they're not wanting to start a
relationship right now that that's not
like that's not [__] though is what
I'm saying yeah I see what you're saying
but if they liked him I that I fully
agree with yeah so it doesn't really
even matter what you're saying I'm
saying I'm saying it doesn't really
matter like it's not [__] it's not
it's not about anything besides if she
was really into you yeah then they would
just commit it's goes both ways guys
it's it's like nobody that wants to be
in a relationship with somebody is like
you know what I really am in I'm in love
with you and I would really love to be
in a relationship with you but you know
what's more important than that me
figuring out my relationship with my
mother like who the [__] would ever do
that do you know whenever when people
say stuff stuff like that I got to
figure some stuff out they don't have to
figure anything out most of the time
they you know what they do they go home
and they just sit and eat and watch TV
they go to the gym they go [__] hang
out with their friends and then they
don't hang out with you yeah that's most
of the time what people do you know what
I got to [__] you know what I just
like I've actually don't I don't think
I've ever said that to someone I don't
think I can hang because we got this
thing I gotta figure some [__] out you
know I'm just not in the right head
space I've definitely been like seeing
someone and probably more than once
actually seeing someone and then when it
comes time like you know dating for
whatever two three months it's like well
are we going to be in this relationship
and I've been like ah I just don't
really it's and again it's not lying and
it's not [__] but you're just like
I'm not really at a place in my life
where which is just true it's like I'm
in other words if I was really in love
with you and met you at any time in my
life I would just not even consider like
the timing cuz that's happened where I'm
like not looking for something at all
and then I meet someone I'm like oh this
person's amazing I need to be with him
right now right it does you know what I
mean like yeah I I get it I get it it's
a misleading question objection the he
he calling it [__] it's like it's
not [__] what he's saying though
is I think in essence what he's saying
is is it
me and it is him but even that's like
the wrong way to look at it I think I
think the right way to look at it is
that she
isn't that like enough into you that's
not about him it's about her if that
makes sense no it's not though cuz if it
was somebody that she wanted to be with
more than him she would she would
[__] throw it caution of the
wind yeah yeah yeah well that's true so
in that sense it is
[__] I don't know so what should she
say I don't like you like
that isn't that okay but what if she
does but not enough I'm saying they're
he what I'm saying is they were in a
relationship where they were like
obviously dating for a little while MH
and then it was like do you want to take
it to the next level and she was like I
don't think so yeah that's not not
liking someone yeah yeah that's just not
liking someone enough to to throw Cofe
what she said is fine to say right she's
not being an [__] or anything right
of course she's like I don't want to say
letting him down gently she's just not
interested in the ultimate super duper
love right with that guy with with that
guy yeah some other guy though she would
definitely be but but that's goes for
anyone they might think like oh I don't
like super duper love but then you meet
someone you're like whoa it turns out I
love super duper love now now now we're
talking okay no we were we've been
talking now we're agreeing now we're
locking horns we're getting into it
we're getting down to it we're getting
it right all right we're finalizing the
paper we signing I mean okay do you
believe in
soulmates soulmates like like as in
there's one person in the world for not
even necessarily do you think that there
could be one or more than one soulmate
for somebody you think a soulmate is a
real thing what is a soulmate exactly
well that's why I don't think it's a
real thing what is it I don't know my
what I think of a soulmate I think of
there's one person out there yeah where
we're they complete my soul and I
complete theirs oh yeah so believe don't
believe in it yeah I do believe that if
you're with someone long enough and you
establish a certain relationship you're
so close at that point if someone's like
well that person is my soulmate because
you've developed that relationship and
got that that makes sense to me that's
great but if you're like I'm just
looking for my soulmate it's like that's
not a thing that's crazy you got to be
raise they don't really look people who
look for their soulmates they don't
really look they just hang around in
their city and it's like dude you know
the coincidence that would be if their
soulmate was also in Pasadena California
couldn't agree go to Guam go to India go
to different places go to uh go to
Denmark yeah honestly go to go
everywhere go to up up in Alaska in the
north of Alaska until you find someone
you might hit the in the fifth place you
might meet someone you might you might
meet a [__] man in the north of of
Alaska as a man you're a man and you
might be like I didn't even know I was
gay but this is my soulmate and he's
like that sounds great that's correct
right that's correct that's how people
from Alaska the North Sound that's
correct so I don't know about if they
sound like that but everything that
sounds
great why trust me dude okay well I
agree with everything you said except
dude
I was in the bank today and this guy
first of all I walked into the
bank that's where I keep all my money
whatever it's not big deal so I walk
into the bank and this I walk past the
line we're going to get off me cuz you
really well I mean that's crazy to have
the dog on you I love her so you love
her I love her she's my soul she's not
on your lap mom is also my soulmate so
if mom was here she would be on my
lap so I'm in the bank I walk into the
bank and this guy as I'm walking by him
is in line already and he goes like
this was he having an orgasm no I mean
it was crazy crazy A crazy side and you
you didn't like the German German in my
face I hated it you know what I mean
yeah who the [__] would do that honestly
it's so shitty I've always hated it
you've always hated you used to be so
funny about that kind of stuff like if
you were getting your haircut and
somebody was breathing your face you
like so mad at them as if like they
should have known that you're a [__]
fullon [__] freak about it I don't I
don't breathe in people's faces straight
up but they're not breathing in your
face they're cutting your hair and have
to get in the front and also have to
breathe I'm conscious of not exhaling
into somebody's face if I have to be
close to their face you're just
like we [__] pass out because you
don't want to breathe in someone's
face cut him in the eye in my eye um uh
yeah so also I don't cut people's hair I
don't cut people's hair so um yeah and
I'm waiting in line and then he he goes
he's taking so long and he's with the
person hate it hate and he's like he
says something to her she responds and
he
says I think you need some sleep to the
teller and then she goes like this no I
got so much sleep this weekend all I did
was sleep and he was like then then
maybe you got too much sleep maybe
that's the answer so like she wasn't
doing something right I guess you know
what I mean and he's just right no I get
that yeah and then she was like oh yeah
and and then he was like or maybe you
need I don't know what this s about you
maybe you need like a a coid mask or
like a a trump coid mask or something
and she was like oh not a trump mask and
then he was like or fine how about a did
she say Helen of Troy mask I think maybe
and he and she was like oh who's that or
something and he was like oh well it was
the most beautiful woman of the world so
oh no no she didn't say who's that she
said she said what is that Mas look like
and he said well I don't know she was
the most beautiful woman that ever lived
up until that point so so uh so whatever
that looks like what you're describing
the most annoying man alive and then and
then um
uh and he said and he said but she also
killed hundreds of thousands of people
and I like she wanted a [__] history
lesson and I'm just like can I just
deposit this dude it was so annoying and
they knew each other already obviously
because he he banks there you know yeah
and
uh what do you think of that I mean I
honestly think that that is one of the
most annoying it is like anecdotes I've
heard about someone in public yeah oh
really yeah that's crazy annoying if at
the bank dude if that was happening to
me at the bank and I was next yeah I
would just be fully fantasizing about
hitting him in the back of the head with
like a sledgehammer you know so it's all
good all right
all right let's do the next one who's
next hey Matt and Chris my name is Haley
and I live in Denver I'm a huge fan of
both of you Chris I actually met you
back at one of your shows in 2016 and
I've been a fan since the early Vine
days wow and Matt I wish that we could
be friends because you seem like the
coolest [__] guy ever we are friends
um but my question today relates to the
fact that I am an addiction therapist
and when I'm hanging out with friends
and randomly decide to have a drink or
something I'll get comments like oh
should you be drinking because you know
you're an addiction therapist and it's
just kind of annoying and then the other
comment that I get a lot or reaction or
whatever is when I'm meeting new people
and they find out I'm a therapist
sometimes they get kind of weird or they
assume I'm like analyzing them or
something and I'm not and so just
curious if you guys have any input or
advice on how I can handle those
situations um and congrats Chris on all
of your recovery stuff you're awesome
and I love you guys both all right bye
thanks yeah yo it's hilarious by the way
hilarious a therapist is calling us for
advice dude you know in my private
sessions I've had four therapists make
private sessions with me I swear to God
and I at the first one I was like I'm
interested actually cuz I thought maybe
therapists would hear about what I'm
doing and have an issue with it yeah and
they were like I asked all of them that
the first time I was kind of nervous and
they and they were like no I think this
is great you know obviously what you're
doing is in therapy you know uh yeah
isn't that crazy though yeah that is
crazy um uh that's oh God that's so
annoying that's like that honestly
that's the version of like I'm a
comedian oh tell me a joke that yeah or
listen to my joke yeah like oh that well
that's I don't know but you know what
tell
me it is but it's way quicker oh oh jesz
do you know what I'm saying all right
yeah I got joke for you you got to be
okay right what is it yeah and then like
you're going to laugh you got to do
something about you know what you got to
do something about dude I meet and
greets God every now and then you know
you got to do a bit about I I don't know
what they they'll say this is the thing
um you know when butter when you take it
out of the thing and it's like the flaps
over like what the [__] is that I don't
know but you do it I swear to God
they're all like that they're all like
that that's crazy and I'm like oh yeah I
don't know you know it's it's not for me
or yeah I'll do that great idea I'll do
that also are you L there's happens
after my show cuz it's the meet and
greet are you listening to what I'm
saying on stage where on Earth would
that come in here's the thing my whole
thing makes sense all together and in
the middle of it I'm just going to be
like by the way
butter people
don't understand anything about what
goes into doing anything that is an art
form yeah and they don't even understand
like the basics one time
someone recognized me from my movie that
I made a long time ago American animal
okay and I was stuck on an elevator with
her oh so it was like you were stuck no
no I was like trapped in okay okay okay
okay while we went to whatever and she
was like AR and and she was like I saw
your movie yeah and it was before it was
even released and I was like nervous I
was like what did you see that like a
festival like by like where did you see
that yeah or maybe she was I thought she
was a programmer at a festival maybe
yeah cuz very few people had seen it by
then yeah yeah yeah and she was like oh
no I saw it I just saw like I saw it how
I see movies and I was like well it's in
theaters so what do you mean she's like
no I saw it on on online and I was like
and then she's at her floor but I'm like
stop you know what do you mean you saw
my movie how did you see the movie yeah
I'm not being confrontational you know
what I mean but I'm feeling
confrontational who excuse me where you
get off she can't
leave uh and she was like no I saw the
movie I was like how did you rent it how
did you see it and she's like no this is
so much more than she bargain for I mean
yeah but here's the thing she's like I
just want to say I like it then I was
like okay well the trailer's out maybe
she's saying the wrong thing and just
has bra fog problem and so I say Oh you
mean the trailer of the movie right and
she's like no I mean I saw I was like so
you saw something that was was it 2
minutes or was it 95 minutes yeah I was
like was it 2 minutes or 95 minutes
she's like I it was like 95 minutes like
a movie and then and then I was like
okay what about these things like did
you see this did you see this and she's
like oh no I don't remember that I don't
remember that I don't remember that I
was like you saw the [__]
trailer you only saw the trailer and you
actually remember it as seeing a [__]
movie bye and then you know
uh elevator like cuz I'm holding it too
long no but it was it's just amazing
what people oh my God how people think
about something they saw after it and
what they think is like the right thing
to say to someone who made it's [__]
crazy she probably got caught up I hope
she got caught in a lie I hope that's
what it was maybe it didn't seem like it
though yeah yeah she didn't seem like
embarrassed at
all so I don't know [__] yeah dude um
well that's an amazing
story it was an amazing experience I
think about it all the time how can
people how is that possible for a brain
you know what I mean but yeah [__] ay
it happened anyway um for the lady yeah
um I think maybe if it if it's a thing
that happens around your friends
commonly and they're always making jokes
about it here's what you say so you can
prevent it from continuing to happen
just
say why do you guys think that when I'm
not at work I want to keep on
working that's my job who wants to do
their job out in the [__] world
nobody oh I do but yeah no you don't
though you don't want to just be making
like full on bits to people who are just
randomly standing there well not paying
you well shut up no I know I know I know
I'm I'm I mean it's just like a job is a
job people leave it at work I know I
know why do why would you assume
anything like that mhm as far as people
who see you meet you think oh W that's
like have you know what that's like it's
like having a name like line where
people are like oh the KY like
everyone's going to make the joke that
they're going to make you know what I
mean uh and you're kind of cursed with
it with that job maybe just lie about
your job yeah but make it very
uninteresting I'm in marketing yeah yeah
yeah yeah boom never have to say [__]
what do you Market ah [__] I'm a
therapist dude just be yeah don't be
like I'm an astronaut right lie but you
you should but then you're a therapist
that's like lying out in the [__]
thing yeah and you see you see a patient
and she's like oh hi how you doing like
oh hey oh she she said she was a
marketing really oh I'm not going to use
you anymore overthinking it so much and
then and then your mom dies and it's
like all right what do you think though
what do you think I I I I think probably
the same thing I I hate that kind of
[__] I ter I try so hard not to be that
kind of person and I I know sometimes I
make the mistake I know I know I know I
know I know it's like I want you want to
grab the word [__] that came out of
your mouth but yeah I know every time I
[__] hear about something like this
think of a guy I met at the Coral Tree
Cafe once 20 years ago and his name was
seven you can't make you can't you just
you're [__] you can't say anything I
said what he said seven I said oh seven
okay I I I don't know if I made a joke
or not but I I I always think of that
and think I wonder if I made a joke or
not and and if he heard it before and I
don't know and that's it oh okay okay
Seven's a for all you future parents out
there seven is a terrible name so is
every number thanks zero is is okay uh
zero yeah zero Z like uh from what's it
called The Nightmare Before Christmas or
whatever the dog I don't know I learned
that today isn't that weird congrat and
you said zero and then I you said a name
is zero and I said the dog from
Nightmare Before Christmas oh nice dude
and I learned I learned it today wow
Calvin has a little plushy of of it cute
got it today cute okay all right next
next beautiful hey guys my question was
about the name you're given um
particularly if you're a guy and you
have like a feminine name or if you're
girl and you have a masculine name does
that kind of like affect which way you
lean in terms of liking masculine or
feminine things my name is j cuz my name
is Joel um it's not really common enough
to be masculine or feminine really but
people told me it's a girl's name and I
kind of like some feminine stuff like
stylistically like I'll wear like some
kind of feminine um sunglasses and like
I'm always like picking out outfits for
like my wife we talk a lot about like
clothes and stuff but then again I own
like a landscaping company and I love
fishing and like I do woodwork so I'm
not really one or the other um but I'm
wondering did my name influence me to
like the feminine stuff that I do or was
that just going to be like that all
along uh yeah let me know no that what
is this question I know I knew a kid
growing up named OJ Simpson he killed a
whole bunch of uh OJ Simpson uh Thompson
OJ Simpson was his first name yeah OJ
Simpson wow then Thompson that's like my
friend V Vin Diesel that's his first
name and he's [__] drives around in
cars and just goes like hell yeah family
a lot Vin Diesel
Woods uh
no it doesn't do that I mean just
couldn't be I mean bro also yo you don't
really think that huh come on Joel
that's not even I know I mean what he
the first part of what he's saying I
understand why people are like oh isn't
that a girl's name first of all don't
say that to people don't say that to
people if if it is a girl's name or
boy's name guess what they know so when
you hear their name don't be like oh
actually you know what oh you know what
38-year-old that's a girl's name like he
knows if it is shut the [__] up I hate
[__] like that so hold on a second
people are saying that oh Joel oh that
could be a girl's name too they're
saying that to him they don't say that
could be a girl's name too they say
something like I'm assuming isn't that a
girl's name but it's not a girl's name
it's both Joelle is a guy's name too
100% obviously it's not even like Kelly
obviously you're right okay but I'm
saying there are again like my last
point there are [__]
utter empty brained people out there uh
uh Joelle H that could be a girl's name
too no it's isn't do you like
fashion yeah influence you cuz you're
it's a girl name no dude this is
ridiculous I think that that's a
honestly you seem like a nice guy that's
a ridiculous question guy you're not 12
don't say that I like him too much to
say no I like him too he good-look he
seems nice he's probably good at sports
but like's he's married he's got a wife
wife yeah yeah yeah also it's I don't
think it's feminine to what did he say
like clothes oh was that the example
yeah no that's not I mean I mean
actually that's Pro for like an annoying
like guys guy is would probably be like
oh you like clothes okay but like it no
of course it's not you know yeah uh
barely anything is actually like that
quality
qualities are male male and feminine but
interests barely are I think you know uh
so no so no yeah that's a resounding no
but I do like that that was the question
and thank God Mako picked it I like it
oh okay yeah because it's different it
shakes things up yeah you shook things
up man Joel thank you yeah but you
should know that that's a girl's name
okay go ahead next one yo what's good
guy I've ever seen a great [__]
Sunday but a couple weeks
ago I'm not going to say who like in my
it was that said this but someone I work
with said to me two weeks
ago you will probably never make it in
the music industry because to do that
you have to drink baby's blood and be a
Satanist now as [__] wild and absurd
as that is it's true like I think it's
absolutely [__] to tell anyone that
they're probably not going to achieve
their dreams yeah I think it's little
dick driving you know yeah just let me
know what you guys think almost threw up
my mouth again but like like that guy's
cool dude yeah yeah but like y dude uh
you can't tellone they're not going to
make it like literally smoking weed
while he's driving doing [__] illegal
activity bro here's the deal yeah I
don't think a [__] shooting people
just how could that be his takeaway from
that the thing that guy said oh yeah oh
yeah focus on the baby Blood Part MH not
the part that it's kind of rude that he
said you'll never make it in fact he
kind of said said you can make it if you
want all you got to do is drink baby
blood they didn't say you couldn't make
it focus on the baby Blood Part man also
also SN gang what the hell is that it
said it on his hat oh oh let me clear
something up for every single person
from the or everybody who thinks this or
thinks maybe it's true or anything like
that
nobody has ever had to drink baby blood
to be able to make it there's no
GateKeeper
of the entertainment industry that is
like I'll give you the record deal I'll
give you the movie deal I'll buy your
movie I'll pay you to Da as long as you
drink this Baby's blood that has not
only does that not happen that has never
happened what the [__] is wrong with you
people this guy kind of believes it too
yeah I love you this guy but focus on
that part dude I said stuff like this on
my podcast people [__] tore me up
after that yeah what yeah they get mad
when you say that they think that it's
true well I'm sorry if you think that
I'm just really sorry that is false I
know I would have that's the thing why
do people want to believe that so bad
anyway that's the weirdest part that's
the weirdest part I know people want to
believe it's so bad but but but here's
the weirdest part about it is
I made it I I would kind of I would have
heard but also you would have had to do
it according to right right true but I
would but my point is I would have at
least
heard something right that's the thing
never once and then people are like well
that's because he's [__] he can't
because he did the thing or whatever he
can't say it because he did oh of course
yeah yeah they got something on them
okay well nobody's ever drank baby to to
make it dude to make it IM and then you
get like the fourth lead in the new Fast
of FS movie right like what's the
threshold who's who's made it what's the
threshold what is the ceiling that these
baby blood PE people who force you to
drink the baby blood what is the the
ceiling that they'll allow you to get to
before you pass that threshold cuz
they're keeping those Gates locked until
you drink that baby blood like that's
how Matthew MCC got uh To Kill a Mocking
Bird or whatever that
Mo time to kill that's how uh vinel got
saving a Private Ryan yeah you know it's
how Matt Damon and Ben Affleck got the
movie made good with hunting yeah it's
how uh Donald Trump got to be in the
movie Home Alone too home alone
too he yeah nobody knew who he was
before that no brok I know um all right
well well uh the other thing is I mean
to answer you might as well answer his
question right is it dick in any way to
say you won't make it because X Y and Z
yeah I guess it's not though it's not
now because if if if you're if you have
zero Talent oh I see what you're saying
yeah and somebody loves you and they
should sit you the [__] down and be like
hey this is really hard I don't think
you have what it takes you know why
don't agree with that I'll be honest
what here's here's why how many U movies
shows how much how much music yeah even
fine artists every kind of art form
comedians have you seen who are
successful and think that is not just
bad that is [__] terrible uh many
right yeah but on a level that at least
it sounds professional there there's no
okay we have friends that so you're
saying if you're absolute [__] yeah
you're
which which people are tone deaf and
they think they [__] rock and they're
like I'm going to be a singer that's
true yeah but even that I wouldn't want
to tell him it's like dude your life is
so short like just do whatever the I
wouldn't either because do whatever you
want to do that you're saying it's not
dick though it's not dick though it's
it's it's in a way it's admirable I
might disagree but I get I totally get
what you're saying yeah
yeah you know yeah but I believe that
guy's good you should keep stick with it
it depends what I mean what he's not I
don't know what he's doing but I think
he's good at it and I want you when you
make it call back on the show submit
another video M and confirm the baby
blood thing for all of us thank you much
I appreciate that in advance he's like
this guys I didn't have to do it he's
got blood all over there and I made it
yeah eight years later [__] uh Tom
Hanks is behind him and
[__] all
right Chris Matt uh huge fan love
congratulations Chris Matt your advice
is always fire uh so I have a question
for you guys today I'm
in Miami for my birthday um took a
little weekend with the friends but I
want to ask you guys what do you guys
think about um birthday PL because I
hate going to birthday dinner like meals
or making other people do something like
this was a fun thing my friends wanted
to come to Miami and I mean we went out
it was a lot of fun so but yeah what do
you do on your birthday what do you guys
do on your birthday and what do you
think about people having birthday
dinners cuz I don't [__] with that
that's such a good question the guy is
saying he doesn't like the birthday
plans and doesn't want to and doesn't do
that [__] and hates
it on vacation because of his birthday
yeah in Miami nonetheless why I get it
he might be like man I wish I wasn't
here he is not doing that but maybe he
is cu I would look he is not doing that
here's why I like that question you saw
that guy well then why is he asking the
question that guy goes like this so much
like
when he enters a room he does that you
know he does he's got the little little
[__] stuggy and
[__] like this and he got a towel over
his shoulder for some reason just I
don't know if I agree with that but
funny he gets so loud when he drinks and
close to you and close to you that and
he and his breast dude you know I didn't
want to go to dinner right it's okay
though man it's still [__] rock dude
we're in [__]
Miami hey hey like this and still his
arm around still taking a whole still
trying to smoke the
soy the guys here the guys like
this oh [__]
[Laughter]
man I mean that's a good question though
let's be honest that's a really good
question that no one's asked before do
you do you not like people celebrating
your birthday I had a whole bit on this
a man of fire oh I don't remember uh
remember you can recite it but I don't I
I don't like that I don't like to do it
I don't like to go to birthday dinners I
don't like my birthday dinners you know
and when you're in a relationship you
have to do it because they want to
celebrate you and you say no and then
they say yeah you got to do it because
it's going to be so fun and they
convince you and then you don't have fun
you know what I mean wow it's the deeper
you
know I'll be honest though I used to not
like it so I completely get it and if
that's how it is I totally understand it
wouldn't fall anybody but for some
reason the last couple years three years
maybe I've like enjoyed that and I want
presents and I want presents and I want
them now you enjoy people celebrating
the your birthday yeah wow really yeah
yeah for how many years I just said so
I'm not going to say it again a few you
said I said two or three oh I said
couple or three I said oh [__] that's
that's crazy I would not have known that
about you I don't know my brother he
used to be the opposite that's why used
to not be true so I haven't paid
attention for the past three years I
wasn't with you the last birthday no you
were I was in Pittsburgh we were
together my oh oh right a couple days
yeah yeah yeah yeah the year before we
were here doing this oh yeah that was
cool that I enjoyed see interesting
interesting um I don't want to have a
birthday dinner for
me uh I can I'll keep that in mind if it
happens I can have fun during it and I
will have fun during it course but
that's because I'm a Master of
Ceremonies oh wow
um but I don't I don't want to because I
feel like I don't know maybe it's an
insecure thing like I feel like I don't
want people to be put out I don't want
to have to do the thing what what if I
think the main thing is what if the
Night Comes and I don't want to do it
just like any other plan yeah I mean
that's likely probably right my reason
for it was I never liked
to look a lot of people love me a lot of
people want to celebrate me so when it
comes time for my birthday I got a lot
of different kinds of pockets of friends
different kinds of people different
groups who want to do it and I don't
love I I've always been like this even
in high school I didn't it's not that I
didn't like to mix friend groups is that
I felt super responsible for them
getting along oh really and that just
made me so anxious I that's why I don't
like to do it wow I used to not like to
to mix my friends and now I [__] love
to make my friends yeah love it this is
him this is him go [__] see what
happens and then they're weird together
and I'm like I [__] [__] them guys
you know such a [__]
starter uh such an instigator you know
yeah well yeah you're like me with my
birthdays yeah used to not like it and
then you yeah yeah yeah AR yeah yeah
yeah yeah Arnold um uh okay well yeah
that's good that was good that guy was
great what a good energy he jumped off
after that you know um he did he's also
4 foot five because his head was as tall
as the railing on the we get it jumped
off he said it you know I wanted to be
clear about it okay
okay me and you if we had hello Matt
hello Chris big fan of lifeline and
congratulations Sasha um I don't have a
question I have um just something I want
to say and which is that a few episodes
ago
you guys did a joke about an Italian
Court I just think it's funny and uh oh
yeah that is simply one of the funniest
things I've ever heard and most likely
will hear in my
life um I will think about
it several times a week if not daily co
uh and that's a good thing um I also
just want to say that it is that joke is
a truly
unique thought no one has ever never
thought of that scenario just the whole
thing yeah about the court and the
guilty and the painting with the pose
and the finger it's truly uh One of a
Kind wow I mean so thank
you dude I love when people talk about
jokes like that I don't like it but I
you do well I love when people are like
here's the why I laugh so hard at that
and they get like real clinical with it
I always ask you that I guess so you
hate when I ask I don't like to do it
but when people do it about other things
I like it when you make me do it I want
to ring your neck until you turn blue in
the face and are dead I mean so
descriptive I just I I don't like when
people break down jokes in like a let's
talk about comedy way you don't like how
people break down their own jokes that's
what you don't like that's what I was
thinking about no I don't like anytime
anyone dissects comedy that's what he
was doing though no he was it's
different if you get into a why is this
funny kind of discussion I want to I
want to poke my eyes out why does that
bother you so much I agree that's not as
inter as gu something no it's not what
he did Yeah it's you're taking something
that's fun and funny and making it not
but what's wrong with actually getting
that's so stupid getting down into the
specifics of what makes a thing funny
that's interesting to me yes you can if
you're just doing it and you're not
like pontificating sucks you know so but
you're you're talking about if someone's
talkinging about their own [__] right or
in a in conversation about their own
[__] because if two people are sitting
around talking about [__] why Bill
Bird's jokes are so funny and they're
getting specific that's okay okay yes
but yeah I guess I guess I don't know
it's maybe it's a case by casee basis I
guess I don't
know I remember that thing came out it
was like com comedian Round Table thing
yeah right yeah like that kind of [__] I
don't like that's what I'm talking about
it's their own [__] okay yeah okay I
don't it doesn't bother me on any level
but I think that's what it is for you
yeah maybe I guess I'd have to think
about it a little
more committ soan Comm well no because
somebody was just asking me about my
jokes when I I got off stage and then
they were talking about it and they were
asking me questions and I found it fine
because I was oh obviously because you
were talking about you but but also they
genuinely wanted to know stuff it wasn't
like I nobody was bullshitting but
mainly because you were talking about
you let not like talk about me yeah okay
now that we're clear on that I'm I'm all
set I would have been mad if it was
someone else talking about it see this
is what I'm talking
about is there anything you want to know
about my comedy no if you think of
something you can always write me later
great okay want to do another one okay
hey Matt hey Chris uh just looking uh
for some advice on uh social etiquette I
guess you can call it um I live in a
small town in Canada um very Canadian
friendly people lots of small talk uh I
have twin eight-month-old baby girls so
I spend a lot of time in town with them
um I get a lot of people coming up to us
looking at the girls I'm totally okay
with that I'm from a big city so I'm
really embracing this small town Vibe
I'm outgoing and friendly myself so
totally okay with those interactions my
only problem is uh when people Reach Out
And Touch the
girls tou their hand or tickle them I
hate that who would do that I don't like
it I don't think I need to justify it
they're strangers I don't know how good
their hand hygiene is just not okay so
what I have been doing is saying oh hey
you know if you don't mind not touching
the babies um I think I'm coming across
politely I'm intentionally trying to be
polite and friendly about it wow but I'm
not getting good responses people just
kind of awkwardly end the conversation
and there's just weird vibe uh in the
space so I don't want to be known in
town as the rude mom I guess I don't
like the way it ruins that friendly
report we had um so if you have a good
way to say that so it doesn't
ruin again that the good exchange that
we're having um that would be helpful
thanks damn this is probably that you're
going to have to do uh I just when they
reach for your
baby say no no no no no no no and when
they stop make up a thing that your
child your children both have some like
rare thing that if you touch them you
disappear they like get
really they yeah you the person doing it
disappears you don't want to disappear
do
you uh that they have some like
sensitive skin thing that they if they
get touch the their skin is actually
real sensitive be careful don't touch
them no not no it has you have to make
up a condition that sounds like you're
flam they have flamous yeah yeah they
have flamous tell them they have
flamous especially on whatever part
they're about to touch oh they have
flamous on their arm don't touch
it you don't want to disappear listen
listen listen you touch them I swear
it's a weird rare conditioning you
become blurry you don't want to become
blurry to everyone yeah um no but for
real the the the second part is that
it's not going to matter what you say
there are going to be people that are
like like even if your kids and you had
coid and you stopped someone from
getting close because you have coid they
would be like okay like they would just
they're in the moment they're like what
do you what do you call it when you like
stop someone from doing something
they're they're not rejected but
whatever lack of a better word they feel
rejected uh so they're going to act like
that no matter matter what no matter
what you say it sucks man cuz you're in
the right you are in the right yeah yeah
you are I agree oh furthermore take one
step people touch people's pregnant
bellies that's
crazy that is so crazy to me I agree but
that is to me less upsetting you can't
touch a kid dude you cannot touch
anyone's kid that isn't
yours period like even if you know them
really well it's
get in there like that's not what people
do that's a [__] terrible way to be
that's not
okay but it's okay if they're your
family right of course uncle aunt and
related and it's like everybody's all
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah but like some
[__] stranger out and about yeah yeah
yeah no no you can't touch a stranger
kid under any circumstance in fact you
could very well get angry in those
instances and you'd still be in the
right yeah I agree I agree I agree not
that I'm saying you should don't but I
agree well she she doesn't have it in
her right yeah I mean calling her out
call yeah try I'd love to see her try no
she she couldn't but um she's too nice
she's too nice because she's even
thinking about it exactly and that is a
Canadian and that's fine true but right
so um to be like I don't want to be
known in in town to as this person a
Canadian so polite right because I do
want to be known in town oh that's crazy
you didn't touch his kids right well I
don't know anything that you said cuz
you just said it as if you were throwing
up over and over again the words
came H sger so um I I think that that's
crazy I think it's crazy to touch a
pregnant lady's belly I think it's crazy
um to touch someone's kid I was you say
that that's right the first one yeah mhm
ums do
that that would be a explain what you
just did though but explain you you
can't just go and expect people to know
I don't understand what you're saying
explain what when someone's reaching out
to touch your kid yes say oops oops oops
know what that is they know what that is
they do because I said Grandma they know
they know all right um yeah I I I don't
know if
um people are what James
Conway that's that's uh dude people are
[__] crazy bro yeah they don't get
etiquette they don't get a lot of this
episode has been about that it is that
it is that it is that but um I don't
understand is there another
one there we go so happy guys I'm my big
fan of the podcast Chris I saw you in
Phoenix at
the hon fantastic so much I have a
question for you or I guess uh more of
input uh it's about my girlfriend we've
been together 2 years she is just
fantastic to death U but she does have
one habit that she just can't seem to
break about you after I brush my teeth I
rinse it all tap
off you got to go
back what do you never seen someone so
mad in
my in my life dude oh God but she does
have one habit that she cannot seem to
break
dude this is the look at the face look
at the face look at the face he's making
dude CR
crem so angry wow so angry she hates it
this is the most oh my thank you Jesus
for this he hates it so much that he
lays in bed and when he thinks about it
he doesn't realize it but he's not
breathing when he thinks about
it
he's just like he's holding his breath
for like 90
seconds he's so red in the face and he's
got the covers and then and then and one
time he did it and he exhaled and and
the the girlfriend said you're breathing
too loud you woke me up and he got so
angry that he started to
cry dud you ever get so angry that you
cried you ever get so angry you cried I
one time one time how is that possible
so I didn't know it was a thing I got so
angry guess it I guess I I mean I guess
it makes sense dude I got so angry and I
was laying in bed and I just felt so
angry that tears started coming out of
my eyes and I thought wow I didn't know
you could get this angry so you weren't
crying you tears came out of your eyes
though when you were angry there were no
like no sadness right right okay yeah
how crazy is that I mean maybe under
under under it it was s sense I guess
cuz anger is dude yeah exactly a cover
for sadness right right right so poetry
but but that's crazy I've never heard of
that never done it I don't even know it
it might have been like a rare I could
be oh Mak it make it up okay okay go
back to that part that is the absolute
Pinnacle of everything Chris I saw you
in Phoenix at the celebrity theater on
the round was a fantastic show fantastic
show anyway look at this uh I have a
question for you or I guess uh more of
input that's about my girlfriend we've
been together for 2 years she is just
fantastic over to death but she does
have one habit that she just can't seem
to break uh I don't know about you but
after I brush my teeth I rinse it off
and I tap off the excess water and I put
it in the
ho serious she rinses it off and sets it
on the edge of the sink jutting into the
sink about that much so if I need water
I can't just bend down and get water to
rinse out my mouth I need to grab the
hers and put it in there for her I've
asked her about this quite a few times
but she just can't seem to break the
Habit how would you go about
[Music]
that she can't she didn't break
down the very did you see the very last
moment yes I okay good cuz if you didn't
and you watch it now you'd pass out
you've got to you've got to play it
again dude thing what would you think
about that the very end is my favorite
thing ever dude
dude uh I have a question for you or I
guess more of input it's about my
girlfriend we've been together for 2
years she is just fantastic to death but
she does have one habit that she just
can't seem to break uh I don't know
about you after I brush my teeth I I
rinse it off I tap off the excess water
and and I put it in the holder she
rinses it off and sets it on the edge of
the sink jutting into the sink about
that so if I need water I can't just
bend down and get water to rinse out my
mouth I need to grab the hers and put it
in there for her and I've asked her
about this quite a few times but she
just can't seem to break the Hat how
would you go about
that dude
honestly
this guy this guy I have a headache I'm
laughing so hard honestly as far as
like things that Partners have done that
I find annoying yeah that dude that
isn't even that's not even near the
[__] batters but it's not even in the
ballpark dude it's literally in the
[__] parking lot if if if that's if
your relationship is baseball that is a
computer so
far it is so dude I why
why does that bother you why does that
bother you dude I want to oh want to
know so bad if that's where your
relationship's at you have the greatest
relationship in the [__] world so
there's one thing if that's the one
thing dude you are 10 out of 10 living
the best life in history yeah so good
jutting has has measured it has measured
every night measures it and the most it
was was three inch you know sweetie can
you measure it please and come back to
me and tell me what you did wrong also
such a specific problem like if I want
to end over to put water in my MTH brush
your teeth first you [__] also you can
do that how small is your sink right
also pick it up and put it back that's
not a bad thing he's like sometimes I
even have to take it off and put it like
that's this that's this I that's that I
got to you do you understand what I mean
when I say this I need that guy to be my
friend yeah I do know you do know that
right I love guys like this
so [__] much bro yeah you do I I I I
I mean wow this is just fantastic I I
don't understand I don't understand and
I and and at the same time I get it I
want this guy I want to have fullon
hours long conversations with this guy
yeah you do at a diner yeah yeah Bob's
Big Boy you know so he says to
her hey sweetie can you
yeah he's brought it up cuz here go so
here's the deal so I'm in my bathroom we
got two sinks right in the master
bathroom all right one's mine one's
Kristen's Kristen uses her sink about
15% of the time why now there that's a
great impression of me no but what's her
reason what dides she say when you there
her stuff is near her is all on hers so
she like her makeup [__] so she'll come
over use mine right okay and I always
say to her babe why don't you use your
sink but why does it bother you if
you're not also using it at the same
time
right because my sink when I get there
will have like her toothbrush jutting
out no because it'll be either wet or
like yeah there's water everywhere or
her she'll like there's be toothpaste in
the sink which is kind of gross to me
like wash it wash it down interesting um
now you're getting into that guy
territory but okay you don't think
that's gross no I don't think that's
gross okay it would bother me because if
it stayed there it would get like hard
that's right okay that's what I'm saying
you said it's gross I don't think it's
gross it's gross if it stays there even
then it's not gross it's just dirty it's
like not clean what it
want so so so um yeah and it bothers me
enough to be like babe why don't you use
your sink and then she says oh I don't
know I didn't I and I I forget about it
yeah I don't think about it again except
for if it happens again right of course
yeah this he's mad enough to make a
video on Lifeline
yeah oh it's crazy I'm telling you I
think that that's the best submission
we've ever got well for you yeah that's
your favorite for sure what's mine we've
had some really good ones in this
episode actually this was as far great
for submissions yeah this might this is
probably the best episode submissions
and me you were lacking but I will say
no man that was so maybe it's Charlie
Charlie's
here dude I don't even understand man
that one was so [__] amazing I I I I
he was in Phoenix I'll tell you what
when I'm in Phoenix no [__] I'm
going to be in Phoenix again I'm playing
it again this year I think I'm doing it
in April or May or something I want to
meet you dude he's he'll come to the
show okay yeah I want to meet you yeah
so bring your girlfriend or wife
whatever it is yeah perfect dude yeah
yeah yeah yeah all right
great wow
dude
honestly thank you God for that well
okay you know I'm being serious if
there's a God that's why I said okay I'm
not sure if there's a God if there is
thank you for that that's so great dude
I'm going to think about that you know
I'm going to think about that all night
dude okay all right you know what I mean
like we're getting so carried away here
but it's I I'm going to in I'm going
to have that guy organize my funeral
when I die that's the level you're going
to what I'm saying what I'm saying is
well he's going to die first with that
level of stress but I just want he seems
so happy maybe not I know but that's why
cuz he's not feeling it you know he one
day he's like God what a beautiful yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the brain
blood clot just yeah it's just going to
explode out of his skull yeah yeah and
and and he's going to and
and and his wife's going to be like oh
no honey are you okay and he's just
going to go like this you [__] [__]
[Laughter]
never ever been me in his life did the
most unadultered just just like can't
even breathe and like [__] God damn
[__] you [__] [__] foaming [__]
he's never ever snapped at her or gotten
mad at her once in their life together
you know but he's been holding in he's
going to die so he's like got to get it
out you know
mother you son of a motherless
goat I'm crying
bro Charlie's so confused dude she's
[__] staring at me so scared it's
okay hey it's okay oh [__] man Jesus all
right well we got to end the [__]
episode all all right all right all
right you do it sign up sign up for the
patreon patreon.com life on luxury is so
good it's so fun we just talk we don't
do the submissions but man we laugh have
a good
time I'm on tour I'll be in Long Beach
I'll be in Philadelphia he still he
doesn't have the [__] thing up the
[__] dude he'll be in Florida
right the [__] doesn't have the
thing up in Florida he brought up a
bunch of pictures of Jared let is what
he brought up uh uh Richmond Virginia
Fort Meers
Orlando uh Bal more Trenton Philadelphia
reading and then Ox nor California thank
you very much leave a comment on what
glasses Matt like what what to
wear um oh dude go to the private.com I
got a new podcast coming that's right
and guess what I want you to be a guest
on it you got a good story to tell want
that guy to be a guest yeah dude yes you
the last guy from Mr [__] toothbrush
in the sink submit yourself as a
potential guest on the show go to the
privat record.com or email the privat
gmail.com I want to hear your craziest
story your best story whatever any crazy
story you want to tell me let's get in
here come on and then also a coach uh
watch lifeline.com for the uh if you
want to do a thing uh gave up in the
middle of I'm so exhausted I'm laughing
you want to do a one-onone session with
me go to mata.com you want the lifeline
merch the answer is yes you do you got
to go to Lifeline merch.com to get the
best [__] cuz you know we got it if you
buy it you love us if you don't buy it
you don't love this you know how that
goes and uh yeah oh yeah you already
said that part okay great thank you love
you
hello
hello hello